sarah has $48 she wants to save 1/3 of
her money for a trip how many dollars
should she set aside so essentially we
want to think about what 1/3 of 48 is
use 48 as the denominator and find an
equivalent fraction to 1/3 so what they
want us to do in this problem is they
want us to say okay we want 1/3 of her
money but we want to write this as a
equivalent fraction where we have 48 in
the denominator so this is equal to this
is equal to something some blank up here
this is equal to something over 48 so
how can we how can we get it to that
something over 48 so let's think about
what this means for a second so 1/3 if
we were to draw 1/3 it looks like this
you could imagine you can imagine a box
or a pie I guess so let's say that this
is my pie and I have it split into three
pieces so let me split it into three
even pieces and one-third is one of
those 3 pieces that is what one-third
means now if we want to express this as
a fraction over 48 how can we do that
well we're going to have to split this
thing into 48 pieces so how do we how
can we split something into 48 well 3
times 16 is 48 so if we split each of
these into 16 pieces it's going to be
hard to draw here but you could imagine
let's see there's you split it into you
split it into two now we split it into
four now you split it into eight eight
you're just going to end up with a bunch
of lines here but you could imagine you
can just split each of these if you
split each of these into enough you
would have 16 pieces so those would be
16 right there you would have 16 right
there and you would have 16 right there
and I can just keep doing it let me do
it in the green over here so if we just
kept splitting it up we would get 48
because you have this first third would
be 16 pieces the second third would be
16 and then this third third would be
sixteen pieces all together you would
have 48 pieces now that one-third what
does that represent well that's that
that represents 16 of the 48 it
represents these 16 right here it
represents these 16 right there so 1
over 3 is the exact same thing so 1 over
3 1 over 3 is the exact same thing as 16
over 48 now we did it just by thinking
about it kind of intuitively what
one-third of 48 is but one way to do it
more I guess process up a more a process
for doing it would say well look to get
the denominator to get the denominator
the bottom number from 3 to 48 we
multiply we multiply by 16 3 times 16 is
48 and that's literally the process of
going from 3 pieces to 48 pieces we have
to look we have to multiply by 16 we
have to turn each of our pieces into 16
pieces that's what we did now you can't
just multiply only the denominator by 16
you have to multiply the numerator by
the same number times the same number
and so if if why if each of my pieces
now become 16 pieces and that one piece
will now become 16 so one way to think
about it you just say well 3 times 16 is
48 so 1 times 16 will be my new
numerator so it'll be 16 so 1/3 is equal
to 16 over 48 and another way you could
think about it which you'll learn in
more detail later on is we want one
third we want one third of 48 right
that's how much she wants to save one
third of 48 is equal to one third times
48 and when you multiply let me write it
like this one third times 48 and we
could rewrite 48 as a fraction 48 over 1
it literally represents 48 holes and
when you multiply fractions you could
just multiply the numerators so this is
equal to 48 over and then you just
multiply the denominators 4
eight thirds one times 48 is 48 we'll
see this in more detail in the future
don't worry about it if it confuses you
the denominator 3 times 1 is 3 and 48
divided by 3 or 48 thirds is equal to 16
so one-third of 48 is 16 or 16 over 48
is 1/3 hopefully that makes sense to